after his car was clipped saturday night
here in jackson heights this is an
accident accidents do happen calm down
i'll give you whatever you need to to
get i said okay pay me up now i need
money right now but mohia med did not
have the one thousand dollars the man
was demanding for repairs and he said
that i'm going to kill him now
then i said no you are not touching my
son and then immediately he hit me one
right hook mohi's son adele watched his
father fall to the ground here on 70th
street and i've never seen my dad
knocked out in and put in such a
humiliating way like this never
you know and i just
did the loudest deal that i could
possibly do i just like i was so loud
but i wanted to cry i couldn't
a woman was with the guy in the
sweatshirt she tried to stop him but
then watch as he goes after adele at
that point you know i think you saw i
was kind of in a prone position so i
just kind of did this and you know
i was just i could hear you know pound
pound pound police say the attacker took
their phones and wallet but me i was
just shaking on control i don't want
anybody else to go through it because
the guy he did it to me he will do it to
somebody else maybe next time it will be
worse and while the welts are starting
to heal the emotional wounds are raw i
was embarrassed
that i couldn't do anything to protect
my father
that this man just trampled in on our
dignity that was really sad to see what
are your reactions now
uh when you see something could this if
someone was trained you know a level of
blue belt
if you knew
you know
there's absolutely no way
that that would happen you definitely
have the elements to control his
opponent that's number one
uh unfortunately we live in a world that
is you know getting crazier and crazier
by the minute and people like that are
not going to disappear aggressors and
attackers like that criminals should be
punished you know to the full extent of
the law but sometimes you just can't
expect somebody to be protected all the
time that is the importance of knowing
how to defend yourself this man should
learn find a place where he can learn to
defend himself and practice that
and that would be good for him give him
self-confidence and the ability to
defend himself but ultimately you just
don't count on people being around to
protect you you have to know how to do
it yourself
and again
those hoodlums are going to be around
forever it's part of life
so
yeah it just has me thinking just you
know because a lot of people train uh
jiu jitsu but uh the butterfly guard and
other things which i mean it's effective
when you're playing sports jujitsu but
just knowing the core elements of gracie
brazilian jiu jitsu is what we we teach
at our academy also and this is what the
gracie uh system is about uh is teaching
you how to defend yourself in these
situations
absolutely the idea of jiu jitsu has
always been prepare you to defend
yourself it's ultimately it's a
self-defense system so yes the best you
know so if you just want to see the
supportive aspect of jiu-jitsu which is
really good nothing wrong you know how
to you know spawn on the ground and roll
around and stuff like that it's great
but sometimes
what happens is an individual goes into
a school where the focus for example is
sportive shoeships right so the guy's
training up goes up in the racks you
know blue purple brown eventually gets a
black belt wins a tournament as a black
male and because he was able to hold a
certain position he gets an advantage
and now he wins the tournament and now
he's got a black belt
and now he was up open up by school
he opens up the school and he's going to
teach what he knows which is the same
concept of this point of view this alone
depriving his students from learning the
ultimate program of self-defense which
is basically the idea behind jiu-jitsu
to begin with
so because the focus is going to be just
on the sparring aspect of it and the
supportive aspect of it the students
will never have the opportunity to learn
something that could protect them in a
real life situation
that is a problem
and in fact
this book here that my father did called
gracie jiu-jitsu which is now available
it's not available this is the second
the revised video
edition
it's uh you know you're doing a special
sale on the book if you go to amazon you
can find it over there for a special
price 25 off
covers all these stand up techniques
exactly the stuff you're talking about
which is the moves like this
that shows you what to do in different
circumstances
that if you get
you know finding yourself in different
positions it's no matter what that is
and it covers all the different
possibilities like different attacks and
stuff like that this is the original
self-defense program that my father
developed back in the 50s for the
original race academy brazil and so
forth
so i highly recommend that you practice
not only this kind of techniques but
find a school where self-defense is the
focus you know that's the idea i saw one
time a video and and this is how just
stressing how important it is like basic
things like headlock escape because
someone can go ahead and hold your head
and just by knowing the proper technique
of turning in towards the person instead
of a way because i saw a video where
someone was was choking someone and the
person turns their head opposite and
what happens they end up in a choke now
and the per the person ended up going
unconscious and now the person who's
holding it he doesn't know to let go and
he continues to hold so only god knows
if he ended up you know brain damaged
kill the guy but if you know just from a
few clas one class that you end up going
to and you learn the techniques you know
from that class that can be applied
right away if something was to go down
absolutely difference knowing what to do
and not knowing makes all the difference
you know down the street you don't have
to turn left or right you know you go
left goes to one place you go right you
go in another direction so having a
little bit of knowledge and this program
was devised to teach you the whole
general concept in like 36 classes it's
basically it's all you need you know and
if you get the basics on that no matter
what situation you find yourself in
eventually at least you have an idea of
which way to go it makes a huge
difference